على ايقاع موسيقى السمبا تنافست اثنتا
عشره مدرسه خلال ليلتين صاخبتين على لقب
افضل استعراض في جاده سامبا دروم الشهيره
في البرازيل في الكرنفال الاكبر في العالم
[تصفيق]
انا سعيده جدا انه الكرنفال الاول لي اعظم
مشهد على وجه الارض انه هيبه من السماء
مجموعه من الازياء المزينه بالريش واخرى
مرصعه بالاحجار لوحه فنيه تجسد ثقافه
السكان الاصليين والطقوس الهندوسيه وجمال
الطبيعه
تجربه لا تنسى خضعها 3000 رقص وراقصه
بعضهم قطع الاف الكيلومترات للمشاركه في
النسخه الكامله للكرنفال بعد انقطاع فرضه
وباء كورونا
اعيش في ما البرج هناك عشنا اطول فتره
اغلاق في العالم اشعر بالغرابه بعض الشيء
لانني محاطه بالكثير من الاشخاص لكن ذلك
مذهل انه امر لا يصدق بعد موجه الوباء
وركود اقتصادي وازمه سياسيه عادت البهجه
الى ريو البرازيليه من جديد وسجلت بعضا من
الانتعاش الاقتصادي بتحقيق ارباح تقارب
800 مليون يورو هذا العام فمع استقبال
خمسه ملايين سائحا على الاقل لمده شهر